every few months you'll see an
expression like this go viral on social
media because it looks simple but
depending on how people interpret this
expression they often get different
answers
so first why don't you pause this video
and think about what you think 3 plus 2
times 5 is equal to
all right now let's work through this
together
now some of you might have interpreted
this as we should just go from left to
right so you might have said all right
let me first add three plus two so i
could do that part first which is of
course equal to five
and then i could multiply that
times five
and that is going to get me to
twenty-five
now others of you would have said no
that makes no sense at all
we know that we should do some
operations before others for example
multiplication should come before
addition and so if you followed that you
would do the 2 times 5 first to get 10
and so this would become 3
plus 10 which is of course
going to be equal to
13. who do you think would be right
well it turns out that the second way of
doing it is the correct way and that's
because we have something known as order
of operations
and the order of operations is the
convention that mathematicians have
decided to use in order for us to have
one way to interpret an expression like
this
and the order of operations are to do
parentheses first so for example if you
really wanted to add the 3 and the 2
first
you should put parentheses around it to
say hey that's what you've got to do
first
but then after parentheses do exponents
which is really you could view as
repeated multiplication
then do multiplication and division then
do addition and subtraction
now some people might just memorize this
as pemdas or ped
mass or something like that and you can
do that but there's a rationale to this
parentheses are just the person who
writing the expression saying do this
for sure first but then if you think
about it exponents are repeated
multiplication and multiplication is
repeated addition so you're doing the
most repeated things first then next
repeated things like multiplication and
then you go straight to the addition the
reason why multiplication and division
are on the same line and addition and
subtraction are on the same line is the
convention there is just go left to
right so now that we are armed with our
order of operations let's tackle another
slightly hairier expression and i use
the term harry for a little bit more
complex so 2
times 10
minus 8
divided by
4
plus 1. pause the video and see how you
could evaluate this now that you know
about order of operations
all right now let's do this together we
don't see any parentheses here we don't
see an exponents here but we do see some
multiplication and division here
so we could see it over here this 2
times 10 and we also have this 8 divided
by 4. so that's what we're going to want
to do first so that 2 times 10 that is
going to be equal to 20. the 8 divided
by 4 is of course equal to 2 and then we
have 20
minus 2
plus
1.
and this is now going to get us if we go
left to right which we should do when
we're just adding and subtracting
is we get 20 minus 2 is 18 plus 1
which is going to be equal to
19. and we're done
now you might say well what if we wanted
someone to add the 4 and the 1 first
well one way to do that is you could
have added a parenthesis there to force
it or you could have even written your
division differently for example you
could use a fraction sign to make things
clear if we wanted to add the 4 plus 1
first instead of writing 8 divided by 4
plus 1 like that you could write 8
over
4
plus 1. now of course this is
fundamentally different than this right
over here because here we would do the 8
divided by 4 first then add the plus 1.
while here you would add the 4 plus 1
and then divide 8 by that